what was the amount they asked in Paris
accord or even aoc's uh proposal I think
aoc's was 30 trillion yes probably Paris
Accord was around 100 trillion the
number is a big number they're like
ridiculously large numbers and but you
did a video and you said the fact that
the Improvement you know it would only
improve the temperature by what 0.3
degrees I think that that was the number
that you said in in a uh in an article
with the Paris Accord 100 trillion
dollars if you're saying there's more
efficient ways to fix this you'll see
reports and they'll say well here's what
we got capacity Factor by energy source
in 2020 you've got nuclear options
geothermal natural gas hydropower coal
wind solar what is the most efficient
way for us to be able to catalytic
converter 200 bucks you were talking
about right that's kind of what fixed La
yes what are some of the things we
individually could do and what are some
of the things the government can do to
help with this so I'm going to
disappoint you right off the bat and say
this is not a problem that individuals
fix uh you know people love to talk
about oh you should take your car a
little less you should eat a little less
so paper straws are not going to fix
climate change no so these all good
things are available damn please you
know feel free to do them and they're
probably good for other things but don't
believe that this is a question about us
you know doing a little lesson then
we've fixed it the main issue here is
that there is about you know somewhere
between four and six billion people out
there the non-rich people in this world
who want to be rich that's China India
Africa and they want to get out of
poverty and yeah you can't blame them
they will want to do that by producing
much more by becoming rich just like we
are and that will emit a lot more CO2
unless we have a different technology to
take over and that gets back to the
whole point of the catalytic converter
instead of making this about us feeling
guilty right now and we gotta cut in the
next three years which will be
fantastically costly lead to a lot of
Voters saying no uh you know that's if
you remember back in France in 2018 you
had the yellow vest that were basically
revolting because they said I don't want
to pay more for my gas and you will get
these sorts of protests once people
start seeing the incredible price hikes
that those kinds of policies uh will
lead to you will not be able to do it
and even if you do
you will only be able to do that for the
rich countries which is a small fraction
of the total emissions this is about
finding a way that the world can both
become richer and better off in so many
other ways and also cut its emissions
that's not easy so people you know they
the the people can then can do nothing
about it on a day-to-day basis so keep
driving your gas cars keep smoking
cigarettes matter of fact double down on
cigarettes cigars smoke out now you're
slightly skewing my point but yes look
this is not predominantly about what
each one of us do because the only
reason I ask these questions because
you'll hear the argument I'm obviously
being a little bit sarcastic here but
what I'm saying is it's the blame is on
the people you know here's who it is we
cause this this is because of us and it
is catastrophic if we don't fix it you
know it's gonna be the end of the world
and what about you and other okay so
yeah turn around do something about it
and I think this is the main point if
you think this is the end of the world
and a lot of people have been led to
believe that it's the end of the world
certainly the media uh sort of narrative
yeah uh uh a recent oecd survey showed
that all the rich countries uh about 60
of all people now believe that global
warming is likely or very likely to lead
to the extinction of mankind and that's
just you know that's crazy that's not at
all what the UN is telling us and it's 4
000 Page Long report this is not the
story it's the media uh story so if you
think global warming is this meteor
hurtling towards Earth that's all you
should be concerned about that's the AOC
point you know if we have 12 years left
and I get why she thinks that I get why
Greta tunberg thinks it you know you've
they've heard constantly and over again
on the media this is the end of the
world if that's true this should be our
only concern that's absolutely correct
but it's not that's not actually what
global warming is global warming is a
problem not the end of the world and
it's one that we can fix very poorly
right now but that we can fix fairly
effectively over a longer term and that
is through Innovation so again you know
if we could come up with the equivalent
of the catalytic converter for climate
change we could fix can you give us some
more examples of catalytic converters
and I'm being serious like what are some
things we've done that whether it's
entrepreneurs military whether it's got
whoever it is what are some things we've
done so if if I had the full example we
had already solved it and I'd be a very
rich man so I'm going to give you
examples but then well I want you to be
rich
I want to be rich and I want you to be
rich so uh uh fourth generation nuclear
basically prom it's a new technology so
we have third generation right now it
promises to be incredibly safe and
Incredibly cheap now remember that was
what they said about the other three
generations so you know I'm a little
skeptical but let's see it there's a lot
of good arguments it seems reasonable if
that's true
we could basically have incredibly cheap
electricity in the future that would be
entirely CO2 free how cool would that be
so that's one very obvious solution now
remember electricity is only about 20 of
our emissions we can make it more but
it's still not a solution for most of
the emissions but it would be a
fantastic start so that's one Craig
Venter the guy who cracked the human
genome back in 2000 you may remember him
he's he has some crazy ideas and some of
them are fun crazy so one of them is
that he has this plan
to take genetically modified algae put
them out on the ocean surface and let
them grow there they will suck up
sunlight and CO2
and create oil
we could basically grow our own Saudi
arabias out on the ocean surface then
we'd Harvest them we could keep our
entire fossil fuel infrastructure and
remember because the oil has just been
grown out on the ocean surface you know
half a year ago it would be CO2 neutral
now the the important point to remember
is this does not work yet it sort of
works in a laboratory position yes
Exon claim algae biofuel breakthrough
we're still not much closer to
commercialized algae biofuels but so the
the point here again is I'm not
advocating for this I'm saying this is
one of many many ideas those are the
kinds of things that could power
humanity and the rest of the 21st
century so the point is not to come up
and say oh this is the one that's going
to be the winner there are tons of these
ideas out there we just need one of them
to work so my point is we should be
investing a lot more in those
researchers because researchers are
cheap and imagine if we could come up
with one imagine if this Craig Venter uh
Innovation actually could become true
everyone would buy it not just Rich
well-meaning Americans but also the
Chinese the Indians and the Africans so
the whole point here is to say this is
just like we did with the catalytic
converter we're going to solve this with
technology not by moral exhortations is
that the word you know thou shall not
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]